so the first kind of sim we're going to
look at a little subheading for me is a
random sample okay now remind me remind
me when you go from getting everyone's
data to getting just a little part of
the data in solving the problem of
practicality and so you can actually get
some reasonable amount are we introduced
a new problem what's the new problem we
introduced it's a word I haven't put on
here at all actually kind of wanna start
so debate by it's very good right so we
talk about cognitive bias response bias
here could to do the samples we call
this sample bias okay so simple biases
are a problem what kinds of sample
biases did we talk about yesterday
okay so if that particular subsection of
the population you're talking to you
always like the same kinds of
characteristics like everyone who
catches a bus or everyone who is at home
at 10 a.m. on a Monday right if you're
getting the same critics over and over
again
you're not getting this is a really
important phrase which I want to write
down to the separate color you're not
getting equal representation your
representation of the target population
is not equal it's like skewed in some
particular directory you're only getting
these kinds of people okay
so a random sample is the whole idea is
one of the greatest ways to get an equal
representation so here's the sentence
that this starts equal representation
can be achieved by selecting a sample
randomly hence the name
okay so I'm going to show you three ways
to select a random sample for the first
one if you could open up your laptop for
me or device or anything the idea is
we're trying to get equal representation
in our sample right so what I want to do
is instead of picking all the people in
my time a population or like this all
the people like that I just want to kind
of pick some arbitrary set of them so
that's what we mean by random okay now
the three ways I'm going to show you are
all quite different to each other we're
going to kind of go in order of
technological fanciness but they all
begin and this is kind of getting your
clue they all begin with taking your
time population and giving numbers
randomly assigning numbers to everyone
in the population so for instance I
could give each of you a number from one
two three four and I could then pick out
like say five of you on some random
numbers okay so what each of these
methods boils down to the first one is
the spreadsheet what each of these boils
down to is I want a series of numbers
from 1 to 24 and then maybe for instance
I'll just pick the first five okay so
first I'll show you with the spreadsheet
now spreadsheets are great because even
though you wouldn't have access to it to
them in any damn if you actually want to
do this practical you have the real
world and there are lots of times but
you want to be able to not just when you
want to random sample spreadsheets
firing away at the quickest way to do it
so you can see I've just got a
spreadsheet set up it's all nice and
blank and what we're gonna do is we've
given take advantage of the fact that
this is basically every one of these
cells okay it's like its own little
miniature calculator okay
so I can get each one of those cells
what just like I asked you to get your
calculator out you will need it each one
of those is one of these separately
okay so here's only going to do are
you're probably used to putting in stuff
into a spreadsheet like like words and
numbers of your own design but instead
of putting in your own data what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna get the
spreadsheet to calculate some R and
numbers for me okay so the first thing
you need to do in whatever kind of
spreadsheet you have open this is a
Google spreadsheet just hit the button
equals okay now what that indicates to
the spreadsheet is hey I want you to
calculate something I don't just want
you to store a word or a number I
actually want you to work something out
okay now what we know what is a random
number and it was this class what I
would want is a random number between 1
and 24 so sorry oh yeah okay all right
so you can give me a rounded on one but
I want this to give you a round nose I
didn't trust you or me to career and I
was actually humans are famously bad at
career with random numbers so here's
what I'm going to type and I'd like you
to type this just like I am now
you might not be able to see that I'm
going to write on the board because you
may want to have this for yourself later
I put it in equals and then the type did
an unusual word now just by seeing it
you can probably guess what it means
it's going to give me a random number
between any values on like Ryan I get to
choose the values so you can see I'm
depending on what you're using if you're
using Excel if you type that like a
little menu comes up that says hey I
recognized what you're talking about
right on mine you can see it's like it's
come up in this funny text so it says
hey yeah this is something that I know
what you're talking about so what it's
going to expect is if you open a bracket
on over to bracket a space right there
just just a bracket okay now it might
you might have like AutoCAD or something
like that which is fine up your screen
oops have something similar to this what
this says is up the bracket you can
write this down your book if you like
come on high and then it ends the record
so the idea is our calculator is going
to take a number a low number and a high
number and you'll spit out some random
number between those two now what do we
want we wanted one two three four yeah
so I'm gonna type in 1 comma 24 and then
I'm gonna close the bracket ok
so again if you've done it right Excel
or whatever you're using to do your
spreadsheet should do some like funny
coloring in there to say hey yeah cool I
reckon you guys eat what you've done and
now if you heat intolerant and it should
hit you back a random number okay
between 124 okay so you want to type in
equals ran between open bracket 1 comma
24 no spaces that's right
okay so we're picking numbers here right
now here's where it gets really useful
for us right I've got one random number
no big deal
suppose I wanted to pick 5 of you at
random so just like everything else you
can on a computer you can copy that and
you can paste it however many times
whoops did I miss that you like okay so
you can see it's going to keep on
continually giving you random numbers
and if you're on um if you're on excel
you can um you know you can type
something and say like a text and then
every time you change your spreadsheet
it will hand you back a new set of
random numbers obviously I have a lot
more here than I need I only want five
so I could say 23 7 12 5 20 for those
people who have those numbers you're now
my random sample does that make sense ok
so this is just a quick efficient way of
doing it it's very very good ok so you
can use that clearly if you wanted you
could change this like these low or high
numbers to anything you want but it's a
very flexible and then quickly